[Music]
good morning everybody it is seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
on the breakfast show here on sky news
this wednesday morning up to two million
people are expected to fly over the next
few days the jubilee weekend is expected
to be one of the busiest ever for
britain's airports but the experience of
many passengers has been chaos cues and
confusion hundreds of flights have been
cancelled and some families have been
told by text message at the airport that
their holidays are off or even escorted
off planes after they've already boarded
what's that about the government is
accusing airlines and operators of
seriously overselling flights and
holidays in a few minutes i'm going to
be speaking to the deputy prime minister
dominic raab it's wednesday the 1st of
june picture punch
transport secretary demands a meeting
with aviation bosses to find out what's
gone wrong and sort out the holiday
chaos
we're here at dublin airport where under
pressure management have to today reveal
a plan to avoid a repeat of chaotic
scenes here this weekend
prime minister fights to save his job as
another conservative mp demands a vote
on his leadership and his own ethics
advisor warns the ministerial code is at
risk of ridicule
the queen's jet was forced to abort its
landing because of a lightning storm as
she traveled to windsor ahead of her
platinum jubilee
i'm here at the mau by buckingham palace
where royal superfans have been camping
outside to bag the best spots ahead of
the jubilee
ukraine are promised a hamden roar as
they prepare for an emotional return to
international football against scotland
you may go to school
shaking all over the stars tonight for
the premiere of elvis at the british
film institute
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world a carnival for the
queen's jubilee we'll hear from the team
behind this 100 foot float with crests
crowns and carriages designed to reflect
regal elements of the monarchy
and dog of war joined in the studio by
journalist danielle sheridan and her new
friend andy who she rescued while
covering the war in ukraine
[Music]
good morning everybody this weekend is
expected to be one of the busiest ever
for britain's airports families up and
down the country have been looking
forward to a half-term holiday but have
instead been hit with long queues delays
and cancellations british airways
easyjet and chewy of all axe flights and
we've seen chaos at airports from
stansted to manchester the government is
blaming airlines and operators for
overbooking and failing to prepare and
the problems are industry-wide stephen
was at dublin airport for us yesterday
is there again today now i know that the
government in ireland you were telling
us yesterday stephen wanted some answers
from the airlines and the airport did
they get them
well ironically enough and uh when we're
talking about delays that plan itself
was delayed the government ended up
giving management here at dublin airport
another 24 hours to reveal what the
details of this plan uh actually entails
so
later today uh the chief executive here
at don airport is actually going to
appear before an irish parliamentary
transport committee and uh tell
politicians who were pretty furious with
the airport here how exactly they're
going to alleviate the sort of scenes we
saw this weekend weekend just gone where
1 400 passengers at the latest tally
missed flights here at a major european
capital city
airport so dublin airport we know say
they're going to work at triaging
passengers when they arrive at the
airport they're going to work and
providing more security lanes and
they're going to redeploy staff from
back room positions to help out security
staff but uh we should hear a bit more
uh about that uh later on today but it's
a pattern that obviously we've seen
repeated right across the uk as well and
it looks like it's continuing uh this
morning particularly at manchester
airport plenty of people there taking to
social media this morning reporting long
delays uh at the various terminals there
uh here's the flavor of what passengers
there yesterday morning had to
experience
after the kid off the cell long we saw
the screen again and and it said
canceled
we went and asked one of the touri
operators and we just said yes it's the
old holidays cancelled
that's all we knew about it and
we're still in the dark now we don't
know why uh two we asked us to come four
hours before
which is uh an hour longer than usual
and we've just been stood in a queue for
an extra hour there was no checking
staff so check us in
well it's not good when you're waiting
that long is it when you're getting told
to come four hours and you haven't got
successful and that's important
busy again this morning at manchester
airport we'll get more from there a bit
later on but of course all of this is
down due essentially to staffing
shortages airports like dublin which let
go a thousand staff during the pandemic
many other airports in the uk but also
further after like amsterdam and in
toronto as well all these airports were
ghost towns of course for the guts of
two years they let go a lot of highly
skilled uh staff and they're now facing
recruitment issues and vetting issues
and particularly uh for security staff
so here at the airport they're
approaching 100 of pre-pandemic
passenger numbers but they only have
about 70 of the staff there to try and
cope with it and all eyes now turn into
what measures can be put in place ahead
of this weekend it's a jubilee bank
holiday weekend in the uk it's a bank
holiday here in ireland as well hey
steven thank you
in other news the prime minister is
fighting to save his job this morning
his own ethics advisor has asked him to
explain why he believes he's not broken
the ministerial code after being fined
for a lockdown breach another
conservative mp is publicly calling for
boris johnson to go as former party
leader william hague put it the fuse is
getting closer to the dynamite goodness
it would take 54 letters of no
confidence from conservative mps to
trigger a leadership vote 28 mps are now
calling for mr johnson to go now
that's more than half the required
number
sky news has identified 11 more who are
critical of the prime minister but not
yet publicly calling for him to go
two others have told us they are unhappy
with his performance but don't think now
is the time for a vote
that makes 41 mps who have publicly
questioned his position
including former cabinet ministers
andrea ledson and john stevenson
we'll be putting that to the deputy
prime minister very shortly before that
though the queen is safely back at
windsor ahead of the jubilee
celebrations after her flight was
delayed by a lightning storm the pilot
was forced to abandon his first attempt
to land at raf northalt in north london
buckingham palace says all of the
correct procedures were followed before
she eventually touched down and was
driven home
sabha is on the mall where people are
already gathering for the festivities
which start in earnest tomorrow hi
summer good morning i can see the sun
shining this morning it was terrible
weather though yesterday and people
still camping out
yes that's right and uh as you mentioned
earlier in the program the queen's plane
did uh had to
abort it uh yesterday
on its arrival back to england from
scotland to home in bal moral but she
has arrived okay that's being reported
in the sun newspaper but kay as you say
it's happening all here in uh on the
mouth by buckingham palace where royal
fans have been
camping out here since yesterday
ahead of the jubilee celebrations now we
haven't had a chance to speak to any of
them just yet but some of them are still
fast asleep but
my colleague ashton harry nag was
speaking to them last night before they
went to bed and she spoke to the likes
of angie and pat who have come all the
way from near toronto in canada
with their two daughters and they are
here for the celebrations this is their
third event that they have attended
their third royal event the first two
being the royal weddings of the
cambridges and the sussexes and they
stayed here despite the downpour which
is astonishing um and they as i say
arrived yesterday and will be staying
here uh until the uh this the military
parade which will be happening tomorrow
uh and that is the one of the first
events that will be kicking off here for
the jubilee celebrations with 18 i think
of the working royals
on that balcony not including the duke
and duchess of sussex some of the other
events that will be happening is 3000
lights will be lit across the uk and
commonwealth and the one that i'm
looking forward to the most is the party
at the palace uh which i'm sure our
campers here as well will be uh able to
listen to from where they are positioned
the likes of uh diana ross george ezra
alicia keys will be performing there now
it's not guaranteed that the queen will
be able to attend all of these events
given her recent mobility issues but
what we do know is that it's looking to
be quite the weekend k
okay for now thank you thanks a lot so
looking forward to that well her majesty
is the first british monarch to
celebrate a platinum jubilee marking 70
years of service let's tell you what's
happening over the next four days bit of
a headline there from the server kicking
things off tomorrow morning the first
battalion irish guards and more than
1200 members of the household division
will take part in the queen's birthday
parade also known as trooping the colour
the event marks the sovereign's official
birthday the parade will end with the
queen and other members of the royal
family appearing on the balcony of
buckingham palace or we certainly hope
so and a fly past as well is what were
promised over two thousand times
villages and cities across the uk as
well as each of the capital cities of
the commonwealth will light a beacon to
mark the jubilee then on friday there's
a national service of thanksgiving i'm
going to send paul's for you um and the
queen
would usually be expected at the derby
on saturday morning not yet known if
she'll go this year it's thought that
she probably
won't because we believe that is the day
that she'll be meeting lilybet her
youngest great-grandchild when the
sussexes bring her along to meet the
queen and uh also a special concert will
take place in the evening at buckingham
palace
that is
on sunday millions taking part in a big
jubilee lunch with street parties
barbecues and other events around the
country and finally the platinum jubilee
pageant will see thousands of performers
process down the mall in central london
looking forward to all of that hopefully
you are too
now ukraine's president vladimir
zelinsky has said the situation in the
donbass is extremely difficult ukrainian
forces are gradually being pushed out of
the eastern city of sever donetsk uh
aleister standing by for us in kiev good
morning alistair ladies from usa
morning yeah i think difficult is
probably an understatement the russian
forces have the momentum in the east of
the country the fighting in several
donetsk is ongoing this morning when you
and i spoke yesterday around half of the
city was under russian control by the
time i spoke to the regional governor
late yesterday afternoon that was in
excess of 70
and so the russians are bit by bit
taking this key city it is possible we
haven't had this confirmed that the
ukrainians are actually performing some
sort of controlled retreat because the
neighbouring city the twin city
lucidchart which is just across a river
that divides the two is on slightly
higher ground so it it is possible that
they are retreating in order to hold
that higher ground and take up defensive
positions for what will be another fight
ahead but russia is making ground in the
east as i say and it is progressing
towards its objectives of trying to
capture the entire luhansk region and
that will be russia's biggest victory in
the conflict to date no doubt it'd be a
moment for the kremlin to try and
celebrate and then we will see what they
do next whether they decide to push on
whether they take a strategic pause or
perhaps even whether they use it as a
moment to float the prospect of
negotiations but there is no sense
amongst ukrainians and the ukrainian
government that they are willing to
negotiate away any of their land at the
moment the fight goes on
okay alistair thank you
well as you've been hearing russia is
tightening its grip on sever donetsk
ukrainian officials concede they've lost
control of around 70
of the city our special correspondent
alex crawford has traveled to
lis gachenk
a town just across the river from sever
donetsk
lizzie shanks is on fire
the russians are headed this way and
there seems to be little they can do to
stop them
the city is coming under relentless
shelling its streets are largely empty
of people
those still here cower and emerge just
to get supplies under constant
explosions
[Music]
do you not get scared of those
explosions
it's very scary julia tells us if
something happens we just have to rush
inside she says
there are families still here all
exhausted by this never-ending
bombardment
it's a stalemate yelena says
two weeks before the war started an old
relative told me it's going to happen
can you imagine in the 21st century and
we have a war and we speak the same
language
the city's twinned with several donetsk
with just the sovereign donetsk river
dividing them
[Music]
they're watching and listening to the
unremitting march on their neighbours
and know that they're next
a number of these homes
were just burnt out entirely i mean this
one's
just one charge remains very little
left of it every room
destroyed and just
ashes and embers
[Music]
so many in the donbass are weary of war
they don't want to divide they just want
the brutality to stop
i just want peace she says i just want
them to leave us alone
but it doesn't look like that is
happening anytime soon
alex crawford sky news in the donbass
was our special correspondent alex
crawford of course on the front line you
can watch the full version of her report
on our website at skynews.com and also
on our youtube channel
deputy prime minister dominick robert is
with us this morning good morning good
morning thanks for joining us on the
program uh ukraine playing scotland
tonight actually aren't they up in
scotland who do you want to win i always
support the british team i'm afraid but
uh i hope the ukrainians play well as
well okay there we go um talk to me as i
said big guns are out uh today what's
the atmosphere like at the top at the
moment do you know what it's fine and of
course there's all the westminster froth
and i'm not
decrying uh the importance of the issues
at hand but the reality is
we've got a load of big issues we're
grappling with and less than two years
to the next election i think we can all
say given the time limits we've got the
cost of living package out the 15
billion pounds rishi sonak announced
there's all these issues you've just
been reporting on in ukraine and i think
the prime minister's leadership has been
critical to that i'm very focused i've
been talking this week about the efforts
we're getting to ramp up work
for prisoners to get them
on the straight and narrow and to cut
reoffending and
there's been all the distractions at
partygate uh i think the accountability
has been addressed i think the
transparency has been addressed we're
getting on with the job i think that's
what our constituents expect should
prisoners be allowed to celebrate the
jubilee and i said this i was in h p
exeter and uh i think uh that if uh
prisoners for example i was icing
cupcakes with union jack
[Music]
baubles and things on them and actually
and of course i was and that's a part of
uh the klinks restaurant in prisons
which i've quadrupled the number
imprisons and it gives offenders uh the
skills to get jobs on release and we
know they're a third less likely to
reoffend so bottom line it makes our
streets safer actually if offenders are
willing to take a second chance to turn
their lives around and start doing
constructive things and if taking part
in the jubilee celebrations gives them a
bit of positive motivation in that
regard i don't think it's a bad thing
okay back to partygate um the pm uh must
be worried um about his future despite
what you're saying especially given what
we've heard from lord guy who says he
believes
that the prime minister has potentially
broken the ministerial code after being
fined for a lockdown breach why do you
think he hasn't
well the lord gate raised that issue and
the pm has responded to it the letter
and he's been clear that in relation to
the single fixed penalty notice he
hadn't intentionally broken the law and
his attendance at that gathering has
been well rehearsed was inadvertent so
lord gate is really important he's a
senior figure we've actually been
working for months to reinforce his role
that's been done by agreement between
number 10 and lord guy but actually i
think those questions have been answered
uh both uh
in general but also now specifically in
the letter the pms sent and as i said
we're getting on with the job cost of
living economy but you have just
acknowledged that the prime minister
broke the law and that's against the
ministerial code not quite that simple
because um there have been examples in
the past i i'm not sure raking over all
the precedence is particularly helpful
but there are where uh similarly i
remember baroness scotland um i think
it's 2009. yeah she wasn't prime
minister though no but she was a
minister and these rules
are meant to apply equally and the point
was she hadn't acted deliberately or
intentionally therefore gordon brown uh
took the view that uh the code hadn't
been broken so i'm just saying there are
precedents for this and i explain the
specific reasons why
in the absence of deliberately uh
breaking uh the code or doing something
deliberately um and i think it's clear
uh from the circumstances of this
particular gathering where he turned up
um was there for 10 minutes was unaware
uh that it was uh it was a surprise
birthday cake for him and all the stuff
that's been well rehearsed i don't think
that was a deliberate attempt a
deliberate breach of the rules and
that's the key point but it is breaking
the law and that is against the
ministerial code it's it's not that
simple actually um
oh and i think the people guy thinks it
is no he's asking the actually in
fairness what i think laura geith raised
was um why in the house of commons this
hadn't been explicitly addressed now of
course in the house of commons and i was
there next to the pm he's asked
questions from all sides of the house
they'll focus on the bits they want to
focus on but it's a legitimate point to
seek clarification on the pm's provided
it and as i say i missed all of this
process which has now been going on for
a long time and every question i think
has been fairly uh answered by the pm
we're getting on with the job and i do
think i do think uh that that's what our
uh constituents that's what the public
expect and there's a lot on the
government's plate with the cost of
living with ukraine the law enforcement
the crime-fighting agenda yeah but we're
not ducking those issues pm has not done
those issues he's addressed them
squarely but there could be a vote of no
confidence or a vote of confidence
depending on which way you look at it as
early as next week that according to
william hague who says um he thinks that
boris johnson's in real trouble
i look uh i i like william hague i
respect him but he's a commentator in
the telegraph now and of course a senior
um
figure in his own right and previous
leader of the conservative party but i'm
just not going to comment on the country
that's not my job as deputy prime
minister it's not my job as a member of
parliament it's to serve my constituents
and that's what we're doing on the cost
of living on crime fighting and on
the situation in ukraine which needs
very careful uh management at a very
sensitive time as well do you think that
we could find ourselves in a position
where there is a vote of confidence in
the prime minister as early as next week
no
why i just don't see i look i allow me
to just give you my view i think the
westminster the bubble and village whips
this stuff up i'm not saying it's not
serious and significant but we've dealt
with all of those issues the prime
minister's dealt with all those issues
it does feel like
a lot of commentary uh building up this
issue when actually when i talked to mps
um and
uh when i talked
across the house of commons about the
issues that i'm taking forward a new
victims bill parole reform bill of
rights the crime fighting agenda
particularly rehabilitation
in prisons they they want to see us
driving forward that agenda and to be
honest with you votes are no confidence
leadership contests all of that is yet
more westminster talking to itself not
talking to the public not talking to our
constituents and i think the vast
majority of mps uh respect recognize and
agree with that that the two people in
in the house of commons who won the
leadership contest who talk about it
every time we announce the comments a
kiss starmer and ian blackford for the
smp and at least 40 of your mps but but
they're not asking for it because they
think it's in the public interest or
indeed in the conservative interest they
think there's some political gain for
them in doing so and again that's a
point which i think uh senior members uh
of the parliamentary party also making
at least 40 of your mps
at least 40 of my mps want a leadership
um challenge
i i look i don't know what the numbers i
don't think anyone does i i doubt it's
that high really in terms of letters but
the truth is i don't know but the
reality is there's uh you know over 350
conservative mps um and i think that the
rema the the overwhelming swathe of the
party recognized what i'm saying which
is our constituents the public wants to
get on the job all the people
who want to see us in a leadership
contest
most are on the other side of the
benches in the house of commons labour
and the snp yeah but
it looks as though it's what certainly
by the end of the month is what many of
your colleagues are saying i couldn't
possibly know that perhaps perhaps as
early as next week how can you possibly
know that it won't be i don't know why
did you say no i can't prove this i
can't prove a negative to you and you're
always the most guard full of uh
interviewers i don't i mean that in a
positive way okay i'll take it in a
positive way then but the reality is all
i'm telling you um because i
talk to mps every day because i talk to
the whole range of mps um on all sides
of the party uh and i know what they're
saying to me um maybe saying something
just different to somebody else though
it could be and but of course the media
will magnify the negatives
judicious okay i'm just saying i i i
think sometimes the silent majority do
get neglected a little bit by the media
okay covert style news conferences on
the economy when are they going to start
i don't know that will be for um the
comms team number 10 to uh decide but i
do think that they are going to happen i
look i don't know that's a commons
for the director of communications and
the team there but actually making sure
we are delivering for people with the
cost of living is really important we've
got the inquiry the cut in national
insurance coming in july tell me about
the 15 billion again no i was going to
tell you about the tax cut uh for
national insurance coming in july and
then the 400 pound uh cash grant for
paying energy bills in october and the
fact that we just need to be making sure
not just that we're delivering but also
demonstrating what we're doing for
people struggling to make ends meet as a
result of your first answer it made me
think are you suggesting that
potentially we could have an early
election no definitely not i think it's
very unlikely okay and i think by the
way when the election comes we'll win it
ah of course you do uh you wouldn't say
otherwise would you um travel chaos um
what on earth is happening well you know
what the first thing to say is it's good
news that more holiday makers got the
confidence
post uh covered pandemic uh to say okay
you know we're going to book these
flights has obviously been a surge in
demand throughout the pandemic the
government provides i think 8 billion
pounds of support there's been some
tweaks to the regulation to make it
easier for the airline industry to hire
and and i think also there's clearly
been a a
lack of preparation for that surge back
of demand of holiday makers and grant
chaps has been taught the transport
secretary has been talking to the
industry
for months now saying that this will
come and and that you need to make sure
you've got your recruitment in place um
so i know that there's a bit of finger
pointing going on at the moment but
that's the support and that's the advice
i mean whose fault is it that kids are
sleeping on the floor at stanston
airport i don't think the uh airline
operators have uh uh have done the
recruitment they should have done and
taken the advice that the transport
secretary gave them okay there's some
suggestions that aviation bosses want to
access tax records that would help them
to recruit staff more quickly rather
than going back through all of the
previous employers is that something the
government will look at so i don't know
the details of that but i do know that
we've made some changes on the
regulatory front because we know that
there's uh a demand for recruitment and
we want to help the airline industry
deal with that look i think it's again
it's good news holiday makers i've got
the confidence to be taking these trips
and holidays and we do not want to see
the scenes or the reports as you
mentioned and people going to sleep in
airports and we want to work with the
industry to facilitate that but again in
terms of some of the finger-pointing the
transport sector has been talking to the
sector for some time now saying you you
need to get on with the recruitment to
make sure that you've got the capacity
because this demand is coming back yeah
i mean it's we're being told but that
it's likely to get just looking at the
picture and say it's likely to get worse
before it gets better what can the
government do today to help people
actually but why do we we always seem to
do that it's actually for the sector to
address what is a a better problem to
have than falling demand which is
increasing demand but we are providing
the support we've already provided the
support and and of course i'm sure
if there are
smart things that we can do together
with the sector to ease the way and make
it easier for holiday makers of course
we will want to do that when are we
sending the asylum seekers to rwanda
i don't know exactly there's been talk
of
next month where the home sector is
working on the operational
matters to get that first flight going i
think it will be important i think
people will see
then that you don't have the automatic
right to come by an unlawful route to
the uk without the risk of finding
yourself uh in a in a different
destination i rwanda um and i'm not
saying it's the whole piece around this
i've never said that i do think it's an
important piece of the jigsaw of dealing
with this cruel trade and human misery
by those who want to exploit unlawful
roots in this country which we can't be
allowing and
are you completely comfortable that they
are syrians who are going to be sent to
rwanda i don't know the nationality but
are you completely comfortable if they
are which we believe they are well again
i'm not going to comment on something i
don't have the facts on but i'm very
confident that we'll do this in the
right way we'll have the right processes
human rights compliant
and that rwanda will be able to deal
with these in
in a decent humane way okay what are you
going to do for the jubilee i've got
lots of jubilee parties it's quite fun i
think the community is coming together
my street is having a street party and
for me in particular my boys are six and
nine it's quite interesting seven and
nine sorry um go so quickly uh it just
got quite nice seeing the patriotism and
their involvement my mum was sending me
some pictures of 1977 and me and i'm not
going to show you these pictures of me
waving oh too if you got on your phone
maybe later
which shirt which channel will you be
watching sky of course okay that's what
we needed to hear thank you very much
indeed deputy prime minister thank you
time now for a look at this morning's
papers for you
and the metro remarks on the increasing
number of letters of no confidence
lodged against the prime minister by his
fellow tory mps the headline boris may
be toast the telegraph says mr johnson's
own ethics advisor lord guyt has asked
for him to explain why he believes he
hasn't broken the ministerial code
according to the times lord guyt has
said he will resign if he isn't given
satisfactory answers that's tamara
joining us the i reports that the pm has
been making phone calls to mps in an
effort to shore up support in a possible
no-confidence vote while the mail
condemns the conservatives who've
already come up against the alcamart i
should say against the pm as rebels
without a clue
tamara is here as i said um nothing to
see here says the deputy prime minister
move along fine
the moon in the party is fine says
dominick robb is it fine well uh it
doesn't look very fine because there's
obviously the swirling
sort of
support around the rebels who are
putting in letters of no confidence to
the prime minister we know that more
than 40 conservative mps have publicly
expressed discontent with him and that
means that we may be dangerously close
to the threshold for triggering a
confidence vote and then added to that
you've got um when while mps were
already concerned about issues of
integrity and probity to do with the sue
grey report and parties in downing
street you've got the prime minister's
ethics advisor saying i'm not very happy
with his response to getting a fixed
penalty notice and he may well have
broken the ministerial rules which
normally trigger a resignation so that's
unlikely to help i think what we're
seeing at the moment is a concerted
attempt to shore up his leadership
ministers like dominic raab and others
are saying
look this is not necessarily a big scale
rebellion the rebels may trigger this
vote and then lose it and
after a few months in which westminster
has been sort of looking inwardly during
this partygate scandal i think the
message that number 10 are putting out
is we can now get past this and focus on
the cost of living i understand that
they are planning to do these cost of
living press conferences it's been
described to me as putting the
government on a war footing about the
cost of living and they're hoping to
if they don't get a confidence vote the
next couple of weeks yes to um to to
focus on that i think the talk of an
early election is a little bit premature
because um of course um governments uh
who call elections without any
particular purpose sometimes find it
doesn't go their way indeed so as we've
seen before uh tomorrow's take at nine
o'clock thank you top stories for you
this morning uh just hearing there from
the deputy prime minister telling this
program the airline industry should have
planned better and recruited more staff
to cope with the surge in demand for
travel we'll have more on that with one
of the unions involved in just a moment
boris johnson's own ethics advisor has
asked him to explain why he believes he
has not broken the ministerial code 28
tory mps are now calling for the pm to
go publicly
queen's jet was forced to abort its
landing because of a lightning storm as
she traveled to windsor ahead of the
platinum jubilee
we're turning now to the disruption many
people have been experiencing at
airports around the country joined by
the national officer for aviation at the
unite union and that's oliver richardson
hello to mr richardson thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
you heard from the deputy prime minister
i'm sure just a moment ago telling us
it's the airline's fault uh along with
the airports and they need to get their
act together
yes i did hear that uh
finger-pointing um essentially i think
there are two parties involved in this
one is the government and the other is
the airline industry itself and both of
them have failed passengers and failed
those people who work within the
industry so the government should have
had far more support for the industry
during the pandemic other countries did
such as america and spain and their
industry is recovering a lot better
hours shed tens of thousands of jobs and
simply haven't been able to recruit
those and the industry there are a
number of companies within the industry
that use the pandemic to attack terms
and conditions and to get rid of jobs
and those
actions mean that the industry is now
struggling to recruit it's no longer an
attractive industry to work in and hence
we're seeing the shortfall of staff
compared with what's needed so both
parties have responsibility both are
trying to point fingers at the other
side and really it's about time they got
together and found a real plan that
could get the industry back on its feet
and a much needed travel and much needed
jobs within the sector you heard the
deputy prime minister say that they'd
come up with 8 billion pounds
specifically for the travel sector um
aviation sector during the pandemic and
also extended the furlough scheme to
many of the airlines while at the same
time
but those were general provisions they
extended the follow scheme for for all
companies at a certain point in time
however
we were talking about very specific
extension for the furlough scheme for
the sector that would carry us through
the winter we raced it with the minister
we raised it with uh the dfg we raised
it with the ca and said unless you keep
those people within the system you will
have a problem come this summer
and obviously unfortunately we've been
proven correct but there was no specific
package for the industry
there were a few little tweaks for the
industry but no specific package which
means that we're in this woeful
situation at the moment okay what's your
gripe with ba
and they're great with ba well we have a
number of growths with ba but they led
effectively the charge of the industry
in terms of uh completely uh changing
and restructuring conditions and
reducing pay
we are now in a position where we're
saying to be a you need to look at
recovering some of those terms and
conditions and some of that pay
particularly in light of the cost of
living crisis uh and obviously our
members are very passionate about it and
we as a union are very passionate about
saying you need to do the right thing
get yourself out of the mess do the
right thing treat your staff well
and if they don't then of course we as a
union will support our members
absolutely
in pursuing those ends
is now the right time to be considering
strike action though given
what we're seeing at the airports with
people literally sleeping on the floor
well i don't think we're going to make
any apology for trying to improve terms
of conditions and in fact improving
terms and conditions
would inevitably mean that we would get
more people attracted to the industry
and we would solve a number of issues
that um that we face
the issue about strike action uh nobody
wants to take strike action it's a
question about whether the government
and the industry will do the right thing
and resolve the issues that our members
face and in fact those issues are very
very heavily tied up with attracting
people to the industry and making sure
that we can get the staff in place to
deliver a good summer and a good holiday
season for for many passengers
is the support for um
industrial action
well i think our members are very angry
and very frustrated they're as angry and
frustrated about the the falling to
pieces of the operation and the pressure
that they are under
as passengers are
so i certainly think there's a real
sense of um tension that's built up
within the sector uh and there's a real
frustration on our members that the
government and the industry are simply
not doing the right thing and they need
to focus on trying to find a solution to
this if they do then hopefully we can
have a good summer what do you want ba
to do
well ba needs to do the right thing they
need to look very very closely at uh
what they've done in terms of their
previous actions they need to find some
resolution to that there are different
issues in different areas if they do
that and do the right thing then we'll
be able to get through it if they don't
then i think we're going to continue to
have industrial relations problems
good to talk to you thanks for joining
us on the program this morning thank you
this is what ba are saying after a
deeply um difficult let's see what they
said after a deeply difficult two years
which saw the airline um lose more than
four billion these colleagues were
offered a 10 payment for this year which
was rejected
other parts of the organization accepted
the same offer acknowledging the
position the business still finds itself
in
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now and people in
bradford have been celebrating after it
was named the uk city of culture for
2025.
the city beat fellow finalists county
durham southampton and wrexham
research by the sutton trust has found
that the pandemic has made it much
harder for young people from
disadvantaged backgrounds to go to
university get a job or own a home the
charity says that there should be more
support specifically aimed at pupils
from poorer families
french politician has written a letter
to a liverpool supporters group saying
that he bitterly regrets that fans were
singled out for criticism after the
chaos before the champions league final
richard boogie who is deputy mayor of
the area in paris where the fan zone was
situated is the first french official to
apologize to liverpool fans publicly
ukraine will play their first
international football match since the
start of the war against scotland at
hampden park this evening it's a hugely
important game for both countries with
the winners going on to face wales for a
place at the world cup we were speaking
to the deputy prime minister about that
a few moments ago he says he obviously
hopes ukraine plays well but he wants
scotland to win here's james matthews
they arrived in scotland truly the team
like no other ukrainian football players
excuse the front line in the pursuit of
sporting success
all ukraine who has this opportunity is
going to watch us and we're going to
feel this support that's 100
so and like i said already many times
to be fair you know
we can speak a lot but we need to do on
the pitch so that's what we're going to
try to do
the ukrainian squad came here via
training camp in slovenia in a country
where males their age aren't allowed to
leave domestic players were given a pass
at the start of this month
in the past few days they've been joined
by their big names playing abroad
scots have voiced their support for
ukraine since the russian invasion for
their nation fitting to qualify for a
world cup for the first time in 24 years
tonight it's difficult but it's football
the ukrainians have decided that they
want to play they want to try and give
their country a lift by the football
team performing well
they want to go to the world cup
but it's a game of football we want to
go to the world cup too we've waited a
long time to be in this position the
players our players the scottish players
are desperate to go to qatar 2022.
this is the ukrainian consulate in
edinburgh city centre and this is a
street unofficially named after
ukraine's president there's no doubting
the sympathy in scotland for the plight
of ukraine and its people
whoever wins tonight has a play-off
against wales and cardiff on sunday
there is a lot riding on this game
though everything is relative james
matthews sky news edinburgh
one day to go until official platinum
jubilee celebrations begin have you made
anything special to mark the occasion
and can they live up to these
decorations here we go
knitted cakes actually we've got a whole
knitted royal family even
even a corgi as well as a live-sized
cake of the queen her stamp has even
been etched into the sand
at a beach there you go
in northumberland and legoland
have gone all out with their model
buckingham palace featuring the red
arrows
red hours here that's the tree i'll tell
you more about that tree actually in the
coming days but that is and they're even
putting her majesty on the balcony up
there uh at the palace one hopes that we
will be seeing her majesty on the
balcony during the course of the
celebrations so maybe you've baked a
cake knitted a tea cozy decorated your
house you want to see your pictures you
can send them to me on twitter at k
burley if you would like to and we will
share some of them with our viewers a
little bit later on
now royal navy sailors have spelled out
a jubilee message to the queen on their
carrier uh flight deck there you go
er
70. more than 300 sailors spelled out a
giant platinum jubilee greeting to the
queen on the flight deck of the aircraft
carrier hms queen elizabeth nearly half
the crew of the navy's flagship stood
strong in bracing winds to form the
tribute spelling out
er 70 while off the south coast of
england
that wasn't enough to brighten your
morning how about this the king of rock
and roll has been given the biopic
treatment with baslerman taking the
directorial reigns the film stars austin
butler as the king himself while tom
hanks plays his controversial manager
here's claire
this tomorrow elvis story told for the
first time with permission from his
estate so all the classics in full swing
martin luther king has been shot to
death in memphis that's all right for
you tragedy but it has nothing to do
with us it has everything to do with us
but the darker side of elvis story
manifested in his manipulative manager
played by tom hanks i wish to promote
you mr presley
elvis was always in my life but i had to
find a way that i could make it useful
for now and it's when i added the idea
of
tom park colonel tom barker never
colonel never told never parker to the
equation the idea of show and business
and
the tragedy and the beauty of the story
is they rise together but when the
business gets more than the show when
the business gets more than they are
then tragedy ensues
this is a
roller coaster of a film the director
known for hit movies like moulin rouge
and while he may have shied away from
some of the more controversial aspects
of elvis's life fans of the king won't
be able
still the best-selling solo artist of
all time and perhaps the most
impersonated so the crowning jewel
austin butler's remarkable performance
it's that tight wire act of of wanting
to be incredibly specific
but
not making it feel like
it's uh the music
it's been done before you know making it
feel as though it's happening for the
first time right now
and and bringing all the raw emotion of
a human being
to something where you're trying to
emulate
and be really specific with the with the
performers set so that's kind of that's
tricky at times
[Music]
stepping into his blue suede shoes would
always be a tall order but this biopic
will no doubt contribute to the king's
ever enduring legacy
claire gregory sky news
my next guests will be hoping the travel
disruption doesn't affect their plans as
they're set to become the first britons
to travel to australia on a new 10-pound
pom scheme after the second world war
hundreds of thousands of britons were
loaded overseas with the offer of cheap
tickets the 2022 version is more limited
with just
young 200 young people
like these two here being offered the
chance to travel and work in south
australia zack is there and victoria
joining us now from heathrow airport hi
are you all right
yeah how are you two how excited are you
yeah yeah really exciting well just
about where it's going
i'm sure what about you victoria tell us
you actually met in australia didn't you
oh
we can't hear you unfortunately victoria
i'm not quite sure
why we can hear uh because um
can you hear me zach
so tell me what you're going to do when
you get there
so when we arrived
already
fantastic it's quite a long flight how
long how long are you planning to stay
there once you get there
um we're looking to do our 88 days and
then get our second year visa again and
uh probably about three years or so and
then we'll do a bit more travelling
maybe around like uh just a year or
something like that brilliant brilliant
um it's we can't really hear that well
guys so what i'm going to do is say good
luck
fly safely and perhaps we can catch up
with you at the other end when you get
to australia if that's okay
yeah for sure
that'll be fantastic as i said fly
safely congratulations amazing
new chapter in your young lives thank
you
thanks a lot thank you
take care
returning now to the celebrations taking
place this week to mark the queen's
platinum jubilee among the events taking
place mark the occasion
is a bollywood-inspired wedding party
wow influenced by uh the royal wedding
of her majesty of course and the duke of
edinburgh the pageant's creator aj
chabra and simi gupta are with us hi
thank you so much for joining us i love
what you're wearing tell me about it
thank you it's um a specially designed
sari for the jubilee pageant
we worked with students from arts
university bournemouth to come up with a
uh we gave them a brief of how of what
what the queen means to them and um
uh
for the last 70 years of her reign you
know and then
they came up with lots of ideas and then
we
had um
paul costello
to
choose the winning designs from the
students and then we designed
we um i think matt can have a good look
at that these are the corgis i'm
guessing yes yes so we've combined all
the students designs holding it there
for us and then we can have a good look
so there's corgis there obviously oh
stunning i think the brief for us kay
was to make it joyful and playful yeah
great um and to create an iconic
garment you know that's over 5000 years
old
um worn by half a billion people around
the world and transform it into
something contemporary
yeah um stunning and tell us more about
the performance on sunday what's plan so
we've got a giant wedding cake six
meters by four meters inspired by the
queen and the duke of edinburgh's royal
wedding of 1947. what's it made of uh
well that's a surprise oh okay how
exciting yeah you can't eat it that's
what i'm saying okay okay i've got that
if you do you'll have to have steel
teeth okay okay will there be something
inside you that we might see later on
possibly okay yeah yeah and there are
some things within a world where we know
everything we decided to keep something
slightly slightly back and and so we've
got 250 performers from across the
nation
uh from red car birmingham from parts of
london to the south east two giant
puppets
um we've got performers in a particular
costume
and the idea was to create a party you
know we've all missed
having
joyous celebrations um through covid and
so this we decided to have a big fat
bollywood wedding
fantastic and
i'm guessing that other areas of the
commonwealth will be reflected as part
of your celebration
yes so we looked at um
in the music we've tried to reflect um
different
parts of the commonwealth
different dance styles we've tried to
input them as well and we've taken
people from different parts of the
community into
the um into the 250 people that we've
got in our wedding party my mother's
from fiji so it was really important to
look at how we reflect the the 54
nations of the commonwealth this
particularly the south asian diaspora
that's sort of spread across the
caribbean the indian ocean the south
pacific south asia and other parts of
the world and how we sort of bring all
of that to life how we bring all of
those people together
so so that's it's been a it's been an
exciting challenge and journey for us
you mentioned your mum she's met the
queen hasn't she yeah in the early 50s
when the queen and the duke of edinburgh
did a tour of the south pacific
um they came to fiji and
and like they did on many uh national
international tours
they um
children school children my mom and her
friends and many of her cousins lined
the streets of suva waving waving flags
she was nine years old 70 odd years
later
my daughter our daughter is nine years
old and she's she's involved in the
pageant
and that family memory uh is really
important you know there are very few
iconic figures in the world today that
can bring intergenerational families
together
and and and we like that you know we in
a world you should say polarized we like
the idea of these sorts of memories
bringing people together your mom's
still with us
sadly not she passed away in the first
week of kovid right
in march 2020 and every decision that
we've made has been through that lens
every decision about supporting people
we ran a covid test center in west
london during the two years we've
just made sure that we support ourselves
our neighbors our communities and our
freelancers and this is a sort of party
for us as well in a way
um what are you most looking forward to
um i'm looking forward to
the whole event i mean i can't wait for
for the event but as we've been
rehearsing with people little stories
have been coming out about meeting the
queen and i didn't know my mom met the
queen
in wolverhampton
in 1977 she said i've met the queen on
dudley road and she said oh she said
what's happening
would you believe wasn't it yeah and
then um we looked it up online
was the queen wolverhampton
and then they they found her in 1977. so
i would have been three then probably in
the pushchair
um but that was really funny and my i've
got cousins in the wedding in the in the
section
and um they were part of the queen's
jubilee and silva
when they were about seven yeah you know
so all of these stories keep coming up
where people have been touched by the
queen in in in little different journeys
um so what's really exciting for us is
to take this wedding party an asian
wedding onto the mail
to have a good time um we've got people
from 9 to 79 that will be involved in
the pageant
in our section
and
people have been rehearsing we've found
a school track that they're going around
to practice
oh fantastic
so that's going on regularly we've got
fingers crossed for the weather of
course haven't we have you managed to
rehearse with other uh floats either
side of you yet or no
no and that's the magic as well yeah
yeah yeah it will all come together on
the day beautifully and that's the magic
of live
events you know we can there's something
about over rehearsing
and there's something about just doing
it i mean
it's all in the planning i'm with you on
that
and uh it's we have we kind of have our
own little pageant within our pageant
because we have sections coming we've
been very ambitious in our
in what we wanted to do so we have
people coming from red car who've never
been to london before
we have students coming from birmingham
um who've never been to birmingham
before amazing and um bringing them all
together i'm really looking forward to
it and i'll give you a special wave on
sunday when you come past where our uh
position is just outside the palace
thank you so much for taking the time to
join us thank you very much really
looking forward to it
yep i will be there on sunday
the queen is about to celebrate her
platinum jubilee something that no other
monarch has done that's 70 years of duty
dedication and service
sky news will bring you the celebrations
and pageantry to mark this historic
occasion plus
a very special guest
i'll be joining the sky news team as we
celebrate the very best of britain and
we cannot wait that's the platinum
jubilee on sky news
meantime quick look at the weather for
you now here on sky
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
well the jubilee weekend will start
mainly fine and warm but today will
bring fairly widespread showers again
showery and chilly start with an early
grass frost in parts of the countryside
any shallow fog patches will soon lift
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
so one day to go until the official
platinum jubilee celebrations start have
you made anything special to mark the
occasion and can they live up to these
decorations here we go
knitted cakes actually we've got a whole
knitted royal family even a corgi
there's a life-size cake of the queen
her stamp has even been etched as you
can see in the sand here in
northumberland and legoland have gone
all out as usual buckingham palace
featuring the red arrows here
and here i'll tell you more about that
tree tomorrow and they're even putting a
figure of the queen on the balcony let's
hope that we do manage to see her there
so if you are making anything maybe it's
a cake maybe it's knitting a tea cozy
then do get in touch you can tweet me
directly if you would like to at k
burley and as like yesterday what we'll
do is if you send them and put the link
underneath then we will
share them with the world how does that
sound yep
still to come on the programme what
about all of this travel chaos we'll
tell you more in just a moment
[Music]